what have you learned from life from the
song The Gambler by Kenny Rogers
you gotta know when to hold them no one
to fold them no one to walk away no one
to run uh you never count your money
when you're sitting at the table
there'll be plenty tough accountant when
the dealing's done is that do you live
by those words the first part of it for
sure dude what did they even mean
because you got no win hold no way so
basically it's like all right you know
in life like you know we'll say let's
let's use a whatever the market for
example you bought a stock right or you
bought Bitcoin and you're like it's
gonna go to the Moon right it's like
okay well maybe things have changed new
scenario new circumstances new situation
are you going down with the ship right
or are you going to lay the hand down
are you gonna fold it whether it's a
relationship you know you're you're with
this woman you're like all right I think
it's time to fold this one I think you
know I don't think that we're gonna be
able to make this this hand work right
now when to fold them and when to run
yeah so maybe every gamble knows that
the secret to surviving is knowing what
to throw away knowing what to keep
because every hand's a winner and every
hands a loser that's like a stoic
philosophy and the best thing you can
hope for is to die in your sleep
every hand's a winner and every hand's a
loser what does that mean I like that
one I like for me that's like the
difference between victim and
responsible like the way that I think
about it right you can be a victim to
circumstance or you can be responsible
for everything in your life right so an
event happens
the event itself is neither good or bad
until you assign it value
right so like an event happens and can
be traumatic it can be you know painful
but you know how you respond to it is
ultimately going to be up to you like
you actually do have a choice and that's
the thing you can control
the fact that you Danielle Negron took
my commentary about the Gambler
seriously shows Once More that you're a
beautiful human being thank you thank
you so much for being who you are for
inspiring millions of people about poker
about how to live life and thank you for
giving me a valuable time today this is
amazing thank you for talking it's great
to have the conversation